thierry ronan ronan thierry suire à la
suite deuxième explosion
[Musique]
voici l'affairé mathieu
ah
oui quand même six nations
c'est mireille mathieu mais mais mais
mais mais pato
sûrement une photo gratuite
ah oui quand même
la bâche pour tout le monde
alors mihail beaucoup plus intéressés
ont la peur me rêche je ne bouge pas
assez simple mais y'avait relais je ne
bouge pas mais le reste en revanche
elle est très bien mis rayon l'accord
mire évidemment jamais de soleil n'ont
jamais de sa vie
jamais chalet merci troisième extrait
sonore
[Applaudissements]
patrick sébastien avant tout 4e
normalement vous devez trouver en moins
d'une seconde bon au moins d'une seconde
avant la tension
à bagnolet ballons récupérés
[Applaudissements]
m
ok
frédéric françois
alors celui-là écoutez bien mais c'est
un peu plus dur surtout pour les vieux
[Applaudissements]
vous n'avez pas connu georges michael
pourtant la chanson how do you really
want your sex highwater all
bat le trou oui le plus
à même à l'émission aujourd'hui elle est
chargée veux ton tour
d'annoncer deux
excusés
je sais pas
[Musique]
alors
je vous jure que dans les paroles on va
vérifier il ya
toute façon c'est un jeu de mots sur ces
all all audi va voler ça j'ai compris
c'est bon là là
je suis inquiète pour responsable alors
alors celui-là des débuts compliqués
mais maintenant quand je dis le nom je
ne connais pas donc regarder
ces conflits oui oui
on a touché avec des femmes combo tissa
megahalems période honteuse
c'est nous les batak avançait les trois
vagues la lutte ma mère
[Applaudissements]
je veux pas je veux pas isolé ou baiser
de voir ma mère
[Applaudissements]
elle n'arrive veut pas accabler pas trop
mais quand est-ce qu'on mettait pas le
nom du gars à gauche c'est à l'aide un
peu
gratuites
gras dans tous les cas on les paiera pas
aller alors être on à l'autre ou des
extraits sonores
[Applaudissements]
l'épousé de
lamballe très
laid pas les paroles ça oui c'est vrai
ouais elle a fait ça elle est très fort
mais là vous n'avez pas quand même
toujours pas de responsable
au pdg de la petite voilà
j'ai mal gré malgré mes quatre enfants
je n'ai je n'ai pas de connaissances de
près et sommes très très cher
comme
entrer c'est fait et tricia bombe un
gynécologue
attention
[Musique]
mille enfants qui vont produire sans
bien jouer
[Applaudissements]
il arrive
et
[Musique]
ah
oui ça vous a plu de bijoux c'est super
oui avec plaisir et ben on en a pas